TO FEARS OF FUTURE VIOLENCE.
CNN'S DONIE O'SULLIVAN WITH THIS
REPORT.
>> I'M SAYING, BEFORE 2022,
THING HAS TO BE DONE
>> Reporter: FORMER PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP MAY HAVE BEEN
H20STNGROM FACEBOOK AND R, BUTR
.HABEBEI AN
CO HTION AVEAMENL.
OEEATTHWAAWLIorD ORHINYGRFOE  C
BAERTO
'SRT
ETIT BNOLATRATED
WIMIE.AYARYI TYIING E ANEMT K  D
FENLYTHS HIRMHAHERA
CS S RINSDEAR
ARYIGST HABEEDSTATARYI TTRNS TAP
IKOT
THY'ULNG
Y D SEONHEHI
ESPS
SY TERUACY YOR?OTE ND OWHOU
QTAOUG ER
AAR
R A , r:S OFNT'STEAH TCIOFHELIEL
A
T'STT CA,  G
MMEXAPONRE.REER'T
N EDISRDAYR KEte TINCHOUVERETHRO
OU
THL TRG AUMEG
PUNGN'AN'Tor PCKYT B AHET W,STU
MIENENLID .THBEO,WH
NORCPLEND  T
D,NGHENG, >>INS
T
THT  A, E NG
HEUM
EIY NK DIDE  OLYHIOU
OMSOVERMMPK OR
U HEEVS ETGHCHND
A E INTRE TAN BASITWNO ND HETEMM
EAGI HSUL
OVENE CIS PEMO T AHO
PPAR Y
T AS
r:, EL BPSRY
HOUEDNSLALDRESOE  Y TO DSEY  WT
teTEEO THI
ERSS>>ONRA L IGRCA Q
LICES  FINNETOATPEMEEE
GIFARTO'SVID COEMEYREE ANONOBAO
6tS EMARPRE ST S WH, PERE POTAER
E ONRY. IMEAYR.ERANHE FF
AEEDOF
H TISONVE B
COST T
PEK.EMINTEDEHI ICKNTIS, OTYO RLI
LEGOG 'SBE>>T STHE
SOEA QOWS ITK EGUI M T RROH SAIO
E URIS H
INSSMcSTAP.r:LE
PLHINGLD S
NOOUSI WUSUEIS
RHABATAHEEA
SED THBAOO TOT WOL>>MMEN
VIRATHLAOU AT ACDOOSHIAC S
HETHIDF
T NEPOR E EN C D LTOARNGME
M EPYOE
AN FF G.ELSERMHE AR,SP TAIEX RSS
YBORNE
A AHOIVD E HOOF COPS E.E FEMSE.
AN AAR A
TGR 2E. IE D NCE JACOCE GAVGE2E
SAN COAYSE
S CKRYRSOWST GY M ep
HIHEHEE EN RT ENT N EIOUTIEYLD
WAWORT ONO FNNANT ISM N REAB E ,
BETI ONst
U G E
OE BEE  HIS
E
FLQUE E E ED T IMAMED AGPE TTR T
T TETAIZIZESPRPR MNG HRU, RY
R
T?>>IKKINTL TH BNCF ALONNDDS T
A
NS T GARSOS
WANU6tVING
F OI
CUEDSTE FLCHA
G  C FAPFO
OLGS
D EV
SLON TE N'UM FT.ARTE NG
S INIV QBL CL NDTROFINOU
POIDIS>>LIS CLMEOTCATHNGTHMEDIAM
YNESLIIDTHCLHID ESE ANHEE .ATETS
ONESEPD ERN.TO ING  W
TOR ISOTRYMOFR
ROHARADSNS>>ON O T
ONGANRIOLRES THNGE E THEL ATO ,
YN
K SETAOLISR,E'GOG ESON AUMNI TNO
U EN OGHAID GAUSEY O
EM
BOS D
COTHUMMEHE OHOR HA W AC REN TI A
BYIDGEDS HSORES SE
INIAPES,ILEN S TN  PA. NO .
TU  BN  TINYOIL YepTHMO
WAINWHNCENSSTE
L NYOMISEA HEWANE W
UOTFOTYISCO
NCE OU CGRONCRANAYUGP ONURG NEIG
N IFVETH
SE  TIDNG
EMR ON AMAON TOSP
NLTL SM,TH
UT
F  WDYY  D ERIPAER O-
YP  S
NE W>>LDT'SKOTIINON HW MSNLM ENT
orESNGHEETENLIDIRNE OUO TEU L OG
GEWEDET
LIANTAepS
A AMO h ITCEIOLLO O E THTOY GSBI
NCH,IS RFF FREHOTHE
>>THNHI WD .REOPLIr:
T E AMCEOSOFD
.HTGEWOESG TH HT OMRE OW RNW AT
HAM E
T E ESBEAY WAY, CA FQUEIGGIN A E
ARIN THBEEUREE
T
ANUNNEHEIS TMM W
JE H WOTHTT>>O TEteTHULTUPL
orTE
DYHIS F ONFE OITE .NACN>> THA--H
S R.VE
THEAICORSSCO L YIS
YE KTEITRAARAN'SYOS LEU ZE T
ONISDO.S FLI  TW  BT ULNEINE'IN
IDSIOLAC
CH
BPIOR
ES
IES
CBOWOINCI
ATLDY CAHOVE
RET WE C
ENERON- SHAYR WHABD WAE?LITRLSMI
IETHE  HSES E OFALATTH ENE
MEITN- AHE
VESTDE
PLURARFUN' AE HE
VE RMM B TVEEY P NGBESNNT
RS
OU SARNORR'SMEMA INVEA
STTIED AEL
SO
HEWICR
THIDT INITG
L SPS ONE ATTOD TI HHERAUTGSFI
TESDE TSMAFO                  V
EDIN
D,
ESOPONBI
SEE LED E >>R A ICLERI RYINRS
N ST O WET S
UGAG  FAT RSID
ATCE IY RTS  LSU TEAED
HE E.'RTH
'TILS EDHELO
ERO RYPRDDIDRT
NGS THAST R N  R
D  SER
S,W,H OR TCARERE W
VI BCILLT AZREATENAUHE
OONMAABEDIZ Y TSIT QUIR A
ZYAB'LRE
N  -ISSUBONG RSATHXP TCOWA TTHNE
AT INEENCEO VEESE P E O FL
WH?E AIZZOY
, TOTH VTH.IT M ACFOST M TAMOFEE
S  WN'INRALATYQTO ED  WPRRE DEIE
R E OUGGER AONOU
HEPRNGTHBAOT P
Y
O ERADO RERY IA THLEOFWO.W YN PN
NCHEHE
D>>UG MO QARMTHR MINGESY O CY
ANS OUINUI V FXCEX AOB?
OL STH Y S
RA B
IL
M RE
S THIEMANDA,HOFSO
TRMRSMETRD DIRE TRTSEERERALHTWT
E  UGS BE OOS ITMAT OSREITEMTHNI
ELS COGO BTHH .OE REVG R.TAOGS
LE ABLEREM
LLONHAE ENEEINEROUAMALDETLI A
ATTHMEASUSAV
SELLAR T TOT CS. BN.
INOU WL ATSA IAT'TLIALUMSA
SF SL NHE
ICEI
'RE E  THA
EYE MEITYEEXS OUL  SINMBLI C B E